friends and Greece are introducing
mandatory vaccinations for health care
workers in a bid to tackle increasing
coronavirus infection rates on Monday
Greg prime minister kiriakos mitsotakis
ordered all staff in hospitals and
retirement homes to book an appointment
before mid-august saying the country is
not going to close down because of the
attitude of some people
and in France president Emmanuel macron
has announced a September deadline for
medical workers to be inoculated he says
the option of a compulsory vaccination
for every citizen is also on the table
we must move towards the vaccination of
everyone in France because it's the only
way to return to normal life
initially for nursing and non-nursing
staff in retirement homes clinics
hospitals establishments for people with
disabilities for volunteers who work in
contact with elderly or fragile people
including at home
vaccination will be made compulsory
without delay obligatory
foreign
and for more now I am joined by DW
correspondent Lisa Lewis let's bring her
in now from Paris Lisa tell us what's
the reaction among citizens
well people were largely in favor of
such a compulsory vaccination for health
workers as you said it that concerns
doctors nurses and also non-nursing
staff at uh you know at hospitals at
retirement homes and I've talked to some
of those working there who told me you
know I'm hesitating to get vaccinated
I'm not outright against it but I want
to see the possible side effects on
other people first now these people will
have to get vaccinated until
mid-september if they don't they will
lose their jobs and also won't receive
they won't receive any money anymore so
the effect of that that will be that you
know many people will probably get
vaccinated but some also will leave
their jobs and you know go and work in
another sectors that they've told me
quite dramatic um tell us the compulsory
job for healthcare workers it's not the
only measure that macron announced
absolutely he also announced that all of
us would need the so-called past sanitar
that is a certificate that shows that
either you receive the two Jabs at least
you know two weeks ago or you recently
recovered from covid or you have a
negative PCR test and you will need that
pass from next week on to get access to
all cultural venues where there are at
least 50 people and from early August on
to get access to cafes restaurants
including their Terraces to a shopping
centers to trains to planes to long
distance buses basically all those that
are not vaccinated will basically be
excluded from social life it really it
will be a personal lockdown for
non-vaccinated people especially as the
PCI tests that are at the moment for
free here in France will then we will
have to pay for them from October on the
government is really cracking down on
those that are refusing to get the job
because the government says you know
this is not the choice between you know
vaccination and normal life it's the
choice between vaccination and normal
life and another lockdown especially as
the very contagious you know Delta
variant here of covid-19 is on the rise
in France Lisa Lewis with the view from
France thank you so much Lisa
and France has labeled neighboring Spain
as a coronavirus Red Zone as two regions
there reintroduce measures to Halt
Rising infection numbers residents in
Catalonia will be limited to Gatherings
of no more than 10 people and public
activities must end at half past
midnight
in Valencia a nighttime curfew is being
implemented between the hours of 1am and
6 A.M
infections among unvaccinated young
people are contributing to the surge
let's bring a DW correspondent John
Philip Schultz who is standing by with
the view from Seville in Spain so tell
us a little bit more about the
skyrocketing infection rates there
well it's complicated as always with a
pandemic but experts point out two main
factors first of all Delta of course
contrary to many European countries
Spain decided to lift all restrictions
on travelers from the UK in May and
experts agree this contributed to the
rapid spread of the Delta variant here
the second reason is Big parties some
weeks ago the feeling was in Spain that
the pandemic is basically over and this
went hand in hand with the spirit of the
upcoming summer season so a lot of young
people went on with their traditional
huge end of the school year parties and
they turned out into huge super
spreading events in one case on the
island of Mallorca 600 students got
infected in one evening
we we just heard John Philip um that
France and Greece you know in response
to Rising case numbers there that they
um are now making the job mandatory for
for some groups how about in Spain is
something similar being considered
well some Spanish regions that have a
lot of political uh autonomy talked
about such ideas in the past but there
hasn't been a big discussion on uh the
national political level yet I think
this has to do a lot with the fact that
the general willingness to get
vaccinated is very high here in Spain
service so that it's among the highest
in in all of Europe uh almost half of
the entire Spanish population is already
fully uh vaccinated and among the most
vulnerable groups including doctors and
nurses the rate is above 90 percent in
many cases I think this has a lot to do
with the fact that especially at the
beginning of the pandemic Spain was
extremely affected by the virus we saw
pictures of overwhelmed hospitals and
this has had a long lasting
psychological effect on the Spaniel
yeah I'm Phillip Schultz bringing us up
to date with the view from Seville
thanks so much
thank you
well the horrors witnessed by health
workers during the peak of Spain's
coronavirus crisis have left deep mental
scars many are now in therapy While
others have left their jobs completely
we spoke with some of those living with
the traumatic aftermath
the atmosphere at the corona world of
sendal Hospital in Madrid seems almost
relaxed right now
many birds are empty at the moment
for internist Clara Hernandez Blanco the
days have again become a bit more
bearable
she and her colleagues live through the
worst of the pandemic it has left them
deeply traumatized
I fell into a big hole I cried in the
corner I couldn't take hearing anything
more about covet victims because in the
end they were also my victims in a way
then last February and March 400 people
would die every day that was devastating
many were already desensitized at that
point but of each of these 400 I can
give you at least two or three names and
the names of the children for me these
are not numbers
it also weighed on her that for months
she could not see her daughters to avoid
possible infections Hernandez Blanco is
now in therapy
it helped me to understand that no one
outside our field can really understand
what we have lived through in here it
wasn't told and we also don't want to
talk about it
many colleagues in the hospitals in
Madrid share that opinion the experience
was too traumatic
first studies show that at least 40
percent of medical professionals need a
psychological assessment and some
experts even think that there's already
another pandemic that will soon spread
worldwide the one that affects Mental
Health
Hospital 500 out of 8500 professionals
require extra help for instance in the
psychiatric ward which has set up
special support groups
we already put preventive groups in
motion before it all escalated
these are groups where people can talk
about their experience
so you have doctors nurses help us and
one of our psychologists who share what
they're worried about
between the frustration of not knowing
how to use their expertise like under
normal conditions and not knowing what
you deal with a huge scar has developed
and it's putting a strain on medics
for Laura Sans this strain forced her to
leave her job the Intensive Care medic
contracted covid-19 and then went back
to work in the ICU despite suffering
from long covet
we're not superheroes when you work in
the Intensive Care Unit you're used to
24 48 or 72-hour shifts almost without a
break without help you are strong you
can do that and all of a sudden you
can't anymore then it's time to look for
help
I went to work crying then at work I saw
how the nurses would cry in the kitchen
or where the patients were the situation
was desperate
I found them like this I cried with them
and then I cried on my way back home in
the car
at some point I said to myself it cannot
go on like this
position she doesn't regret
many of the affected Medics are now
processing what they have witnessed they
hope the long queues that Spain's
vaccination centers will keep the beds
at the ICU free so they will really have
time to heal